Personally,
it's a very,
very complicated answer.
I think they should definitely be there
as a last resort and probably for
catastrophic health insurance,
but I think you know,
there's a question,
well,
should the government pay for
healthcare?
And if you say yes to that and think you
solved the problem,
you haven't because the question
becomes,
well,
how much healthcare should they pay for?
Should they pay for the 80 year old lady
who's a vegetable to stay alive?
Another six months?
Should they pay for the liver transplant
of the 40 year old alcoholic,
uh,
should they pay for the,
the operation on the guy who refused to
wear his helmet and the motorcycle up?
Our resources are finite and we need to
do a much better job of figuring out
where we spend them in where we don't.
And right now we make a lot of these
decisions opaquely.
If you're black and poor,
chances are you're not going to get good
healthcare care if you're rich and
white.
Even if you didn't pay your insurance,
chances are you know somebody who knows
somebody at Mount Sinai,
so you're going to get better cancer
operation.
You live in Iowa and there's a certain
operation that might cure you,
but they offered only in Seattle,
you're probably not going to get that
operation and we're never going to have
a world of equality of outcome,
but we should at least have a world of
equality of opportunity and we shouldn't
kid ourselves that.
Every life is infinitely more valuable
than anything else.
We make trade offs all the time.
We.
We don't feed children right in school.
We we destroy lives much earlier than
when they show up in the hospital and so
the problem is we don't like to confront
these decisions just as you might not
like to confront decisions about that.
I mentioned earlier that your personal
life,
we as a society feel uncomfortable with
explicit rules.
Yet those things get adjudicated all the
time.
Just quietly,
and I didn't really answer your
question,
but I think at the at the day to day
care,
people should pay their own costs,
but the.
The real issue is how it had to design a
system than incentivize healthy behavior
because most of the healthcare costs in
this country are due to either end of
life or what is essentially the results
of bad behavior.
Uh,
heart disease,
lung cancer,
diabetes,
they're not assigned that you've been
bad,
but they are aggravated by poor
nutritional habits,
lack of exercise,
all these things.
And if we could just get people to adopt
much healthier lifestyles or medical
costs will go down,
but I don't really want the government
monitoring what people eat either.
So the challenge is how to change social
norms without brainwashing people,
let them understand their genetic
information,
educate them better at school.
And I mean it really the,
the one that's,
you know,
Mcdonald's has a huge role to play in
this just by what they offer people to
eat.
If,
if the food companies could start
promoting genuinely healthy food rather
than kind of what does it truthiness
fruitiness where you put chemicals into
something and claim that it's more
healthy because it has some kind of one
piece of nutrition.
It's sort of like if you put please into
something saying that it's polite,
you know,
and the thing is still rude,
so it's,
it's extremely complicated and more
information is a start more information
about the impact of the kind of food we
just as in the environment,
more information about the impact of the
kinds of things we drive or the stuff we
use or the cost of air conditioning,
that kind of thing.